it's about the planet is beautiful  anterior to come Courage's local people  and physically as well in class streets  parts of each is all nice and clean and  free from it local residents and  visitors ceramic can win so I panic and  send in photographs and videos of their  favorite place in famines whether that's  a park a beach an open space town center  or even little Gardens I do hope you're  going to enter the competition and any  entries you can find details on how to  enter on the bottom of this cage I think  Panik is beautiful I was an opportunity  out there now for you to think planet is  beautiful so please enter and show us  all these other secret little places  around in panic